the U.S government is investing 22
million dollars into developing
surveillance clothing that includes
shirts pants and underwear
that can record video and audio the US
government has invented 20 million
dollars smart electricity
powered and networked textile systems
called smart e-pants program aiming to
create weapon a wearable clothing
capable of recording audio video and
geolocation data the program's goal is
to produce washable garments including
shirts pants socks and underwear with
Advanced surveillance capabilities the
office of the director of intelligence
states that is smartypants represents
significant investment and develop an
active smart textiles Dr Dawson kagold
the program manager for smart e-pans
highlighted the potential benefits for
government agencies like the Department
of Defense Department of Homeland
Security and intelligence Community he
notes that wearable technology could
enhance situational awareness by
allowing users to keep their hands free
in high stress environment Dr Kegel Dr
Kegel that's hilarious is that how you
turn it on you do it quick yo
can you imagine that like like that's
going to be the future
I have to tell you a secret like I can't
my underwear are listening yeah it's
like well think about it they're trying
to make Pat this is uh Brandon made this
a good point on my show yesterday the
Vincent ochana show Wednesdays yeah the
brand they're making surveillance cool
they're making it stylish just like with
Facebook do you remember during the
Obama they were like Obama's or it's our
privacy and everybody's fighting we
don't want them to know about I
don't know where I don't want you to
follow me or all of a sudden Facebook
comes out and you're willingly telling
them where you eat who you hang out with
what your style is what concerts you
watch like the CIA must worship Mark
Zuckerberg because they made it what
cool difference a decade makes exactly
time now it's cool this is my privacy I
can't believe you're doing this and then
it's like okay now it's like you're not
on Facebook number one let's go Brandon
congrats for you John Brandon number two
where was this technology when Larry
Sinclair was smoking crack with Obama no
photos I'm sorry sorry as Obama was
stopping down lyrics
never mind if he had those pants
technology so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]